Thank you very much.
Well first of all,
thank you to a Google for inviting me
here to speak to you and thank you for
coming in.
What do I suppose is your lunch time
to listen to math during a lunch break,
which is pretty amazing.
So I am going to talk about logic and
about how to make sense in a world that
doesn't because a lot of the world
does not make sense at the moment in
particular. Many people don't seem to
make sense in the world at the moment.
And I have previously written books to
show how maths is fun and delicious and
amazing and this is less about how it's
fun and more about how it's important
because the previous books
were about how it's important,
but recent events in the last couple of
years have driven me to feeling the need
to say slightly more urgent and more dare
I say political things about how maths
can help us.
And this might be surprising because
usually pure maths is thought of as being
pure and remote. I am a pure
mathematician, I am a category theorist.
That is my research and category theory
is sometimes thought of as the most
abstract type of mathematics.
Well,
I say that pure math is a
framework for agreeing on things,
but in general pure maths is often thought
of as really only being relevant to
applied math and applied math is
then helpful to science possibly.
And Science is helpful to engineering
and medicine and engineering and medicine
are helpful to the world and maths is
helpful to kind of the numerical part of
the world. And we might think
of differential equations
or solving equations and
calculating things and finance
and science and business and,
and those are the ways in which math is
useful, but that enables people to say,
well that's fine. I'm glad somebody
does that, but it doesn't have to be me.
It's not relevant to me.
Someone else can do it.
And I'm sure many of you do do it.
And there are many people in the world
who just ignore it and hope for the best.
Well,
I say that actually because pure maths
is a framework for agreeing on things.
It's a framework for how to think well
and because it's about how to think,
it's actually about the entire human
world or at least the part of the human
world that thinks,
which might not be all of it.
But once it be great if everyone were
able to think better. That's what I say.
And I truly believe that pure mathematics
is a discipline for thinking better
and for how to have better
arguments because I don't,
I'm not claiming to tell
everyone what to think,
but I wish we could have better arguments
because at the moment we seem to be
myered in conflict device.
If for argument's fake news,
yelling, bigotry, prejudice,
hate exploitation,
victim hood,
and it doesn't seem like it can sometimes
seem like there is not a productive
way to have a discussion,
but I think there is a productive
way to have discussion.
It just might not be on social media
necessarily, but maybe we can try.
And so this is what my book is about.
It's about how can we have more productive
conversations using lessons from
abstract mathematics.
So I'm going to talk about analogies
and how pure maths uses analogies.
I'm going to talk about
the interconnectedness of
things and how we should
always think about how
things are interconnected.
Going to talk about
relationships or various kinds.
I'm going to talk about pivoting between
different contexts so that we can help
ourselves understand all the people
from their point of view. And finally,
I'm going to talk about what I think
intelligence really actually is.
So first of all,
analogies,
I say that pure maths is a
framework for agreeing on things.
It's also a theory of analogies because
fundamentally what it says is there are
lots of different situations
that have something in common.
If we just forget some of
the pesky details about them.
And then that takes us from the real
world of things into the abstract world of
ideas where more things
become the same by analogy,
but what pure maths does that we don't
necessarily do a normal life is we make
very precise what the analogy is.
We don't just say this thing
is analogous to that. We say,
what is the analogy that
we're thinking about here?
And that removes a lot of ambiguity
and having a framework for agreeing on
things is partly about
removing possible ambiguity's.
So here is an example of how this works.
It's a very basic level.
If you think about two apples
and two bananas, then you can go,
oh these things have something in common.
They're both two things and
that's how we get the number two.
It's an analogy between a lot of different
sets of two things and when we first
teach small children how to count,
we have to wait for them to make that
abstract leap from the object in front of
them to the concept.
And you can't really do that for them.
You just have to sort of wait to show
them over and over again and wait until
they make that leap.
It's a leap of abstraction.
Now there are other ways
we could have done this.
We could instead have said that they're
both two fruits, which is still true.
It just encompasses less stuff.
So if we had instead made
the analogy via two fruits,
then we would not be able to encompass
two chairs in this because that is not to
fruits.
This doesn't mean it's a wrong analogy.
It just means it's an analogy to different
level that encompasses fewer things.
Whereas now if we go all
the way up to two things,
then we get to encompass the two
chairs as well. And pure maths.
A lots of pure math is about finding
the right level for the situation that
you're in.
It's not that there is one absolutely
right level maths as it turns out is not
about getting the right answer.
It's about different points of view
that illuminates situations in different
ways.
And I think arguments in life are often
not really about one person being right
and one person being wrong,
but a sense in which something is right.
So here is the sense in which two chairs
are not analogous to two bananas along
with a sense in which they are.
And then once we've made precise
those two different levels,
we can then have a discussion about which
one is a better level to use for the
current discussion. And this happens
at a more profound level in maths.
When we think about say one plus two and
we compare that to two plus three and
this is where that thing happens that
makes some people very scared where the
numbers turn into letters and these
are both examples of a plus B,
but the point of doing that
is not to terrify everyone,
although that can sometimes be
what it seems like the point,
the point is to encompass more examples.
That's always the idea of abstraction,
to study a lot of different things at
the same time to save your brainpower and
be more efficient,
and this is a good thing to do if you're
lazy like me and you don't want to do
the same thing over and over again,
and I said lots of pure maths
comes from that. You've,
you do the same thing a few times and you
go, oh, I don't want to do that anymore.
I'm going to make a theory
that will do it for me.
So you kind of front load your effort and
then you never have to make the effort
ever again like getting a dishwasher.
So this is very similar to one times
two and two times three which can be
abstracted to a times B.
But now we can say that whole left hand
part is analogous to the entire right
hand part. And these are both
an example of a something.
Be there aware of combining.
So I'm a and some B and so we can go
even one level more abstract and say this
is a blur B and it's a way
of combining two things.
This is called a binary operation in
mathematics and it's one level more
abstract that you probably only see if
you do an undergraduate degree in maths.
And you do something like group theory
where you look at things with binary
operations.
Now sometimes the top level is a really
good place to look and sometimes the
middle level is a better place to look.
It just depends what you're trying to do.
So if you're thinking about something
like one plus two equals two plus one
which you might remember is the
Commuter Nativity of addition.
There's also a commuter
activity of multiplication,
which says that one times two equals two
times one and a times B equals B times
a.
And if we go up to the top level,
we can study both of those
phenomena at the same time. However,
if we want to look at undoing the process,
we can't talk to the top
level because at that level,
addition and multiplication aren't
the same because you can't always,
you can't always undo the process of
multiplication because if you multiply by
zero, you can't undo that you're
done. Whereas whatever you add,
you can always subtract
it to get back again.
You can divide by any number apart
from zero. And so at that level,
addition and multiplication on not
analogous. So we have to pick carefully.
And the main point of talking about this
is to show that making precise which
level we're talking about helps us to
be clear about what's going to be useful
now and what isn't isn't
true in in that context.
So a more real life example.
And my book is full of actual life.
Examples of things that people argue
about on the Internet all the time is when
a straight marriage and
gay marriage or analogous.
So people say that they do not believe
that gay people should be allowed to
marry each other because they think that
marriage should be between a man and a
woman. Now that is not
exactly an illogical argument,
but it's also not a very profound argument
because all they've really done is
said the same thing twice.
So if I say I like orange juice
because I like orange juice,
but it's not illogical,
it just hasn't got anywhere at all.
You haven't achieved anything.
And so just being logical versus illogical
is not the be all and end all of what
an intelligent person should try and do.
What we should try and do is actually
make progress and gain understanding,
not just say the same thing over and
over again with slightly different words.
So the sense in which these two things
are not analogous is if you do think that
marriage is about an unrelated man and
woman and then it is true that same sex
marriage does not come under that.
However,
if you think that it is
about two unrelated adults,
then same sex marriage
does come under that.
And the question shouldn't be whether
those things are the same or not.
There's questions should be which level
is a good level for us to consider.
Now the next thing that happens if you
go as far as this is that somebody will
get really upset and say,
oh well the next thing you know we're,
we'll be allowing incest.
And so what they've done is they've gone
up a further level and going up to the
level of two adults and then
the next thing you know,
you could go up to the level of just two
humans and then the next thing you know,
you could go up to the level of two living
creatures and then you could just go
up to the level of two creatures.
This is the slide that
could have been redacted.
Have there been any minors in the room?
Now,
all of these levels are logically valid.
I would argue that some of them
are not very morally valid,
but that's a different question and what
is certainly not logically valid is to
claim that just because somebody
has accepted this level,
some people claim that means that you've
accepted all the other levels and that
is not logically valid. So once we've
made precise what all these levels are,
we can now have a discussion about which
level anyone thinks that we should go
up too. But we should not
conflate all the different levels.
And the trouble with not making those
levels precise is that somebody can
hallucinate,
willfully or otherwise that somebody
else has shot all the way up to the top
when they haven't.
So this is one of the advantages I
think of the precision of abstract
mathematics.
I'd now like to move on to talking
about the interconnectedness of things
because everything is interconnected.
Unfortunately,
many people often like to blame exactly
one thing or exactly one person or one
group of people.
And that is a way to simplify situations.
But I don't think it's a very good way.
And yes,
we are all trying to make
sense of a complicated world
and that requires somehow
simplifying the world,
but just ignoring huge quantities of it
is not a great way of doing it. I think.
I think that a better way of doing it is
to become more intelligent because then
the world becomes simpler relative to
your intelligence and then new simplified
the world.
So here is one of my favorite
diagrams of interconnectedness.
We will know this picture. It's not
a geographically accurate picture.
It doesn't show geographical location.
And what it shows is the
interconnectedness of stations
by different two blinds.
And this is all we need to know if we're
trying to get from one tube station to
another.
Once we are in the train,
we don't really need to know exactly
where the tunnel goes necessarily.
We just need to know where it's
going to pop out out. And uh,
this does mean the hapless tourists
sometimes find themselves taking the tube
ridiculous distance because they didn't
realize that actually if they just went
above ground,
it was two minutes walk that way.
This is an abstract picture because it's
just showing the interconnectedness of
things.
This is the geographical tumor picture.
It is much harder to understand if you're
trying to use it to get from a to B,
but that doesn't mean it's worthless.
It's quite interesting to see where the
tube lines actually go and to see where
the tube stations really are in London.
I think so it's not that one of these
is right and one of them is wrong.
It's just that it depends what you're
trying to achieve and that depending on
what you're trying to achieve,
you should look at the things that are
relevant to the thing you're trying to
achieve or understand and then be able
to switch between thinking about relevant
these things in this situation and
those things in that situation,
and that's one of the things that
abstract mathematics does a lot is that it
doesn't say this is actually the
full explanation of this situation.
It says here is an explanation of an
aspect of this situation and in another on
another day when we're
worrying about something else,
we can think about another aspect.
Relationship breakdown is something that
involves a lot of interconnectedness
and also a lot of blame.
And often when relationships break down,
everyone blames one person and then the
other people all blame the other person.
So often people take sides and often
the people in the relationship breakdown
tech sites.
Now there are situations where it might
really be one person's fault in cases of
extreme domestic abuse.
But usually it's about a breakdown
of things going in both directions.
And here's an example
of how I think about it.
Sometimes supposing Alex is someone who
doesn't like feeling disrespected and if
Alex feels disrespected,
then Alex is unable to show love
and there may be Alex's partner.
Sam is someone who really likes to
feel loved. And if Sam feels unloved,
then Sam is unable to show respect,
in which case Alex feels disrespected
and we get in this cycle and it can get
worse and worse and worse. Now I can
classify these arrows in different ways.
So these are,
these are errors about action that
people take in response to something.
And these arrows are about feelings that
people have in response to something.
And this can get into a
very bad vicious cycle.
Once we've seen it's this vicious cycle.
By the end of the
connectedness of these arrows,
we can think about how to break the cycle.
We can think about which of
these arrows is the easy,
the weakest one that we could break.
We can think about whether it's diff,
more difficult to change your
feelings or your actions.
I think it's harder to change
feelings because feelings just are,
you just respond to things, but you
don't have to act on those feelings.
But some other people think that they
can't stop themselves acting on those
feelings,
so they have to change their feelings.
But at least we can then have a clear
discussion about what's going on in this
situation.
Now there's an analogous situation that
is to say it makes the same picture
that's possibly more urgents,
which is about police
violence against black people.
This is a particular issue in America,
um,
where we have another vicious
circle that looks like this,
that involves maybe police who
feel threatened by black people,
and that means that they aggressively
defend themselves against black people.
But in turn that means that black people
feel very threatened by the police,
which means that black people aggressively
defend themselves against the police,
which means that police feel
threatened by black people, and again,
this separates out into feeling responses
and action responses and once we've
observed that there is this
interconnectedness of causes,
then we can have I think a
more productive argument.
Instead of half the people on
the Internet yelling, well,
they should just do what the police told
him and then they won't get shot and
the other half saying, well, the
deletion shoot them. That's one birth.
I think that we can look at this
interconnectedness and saying,
there are many things going on now.
Whose responsibility is
it to change something?
I think in this situation and
in a relationship breakdown,
whoever has more power in the situation
should take the responsibility for
changing it, but maybe some
people disagree with me at least.
Then we can talk about really what we
disagree with rather than having futile
shouting matches across the internet.
I use the interconnectedness of
things to help me understand difficult
situations that have arisen when people
are yelling about exactly who is to
blame.
So one case where I drew a diagram that
looks like a category theory diagram to
me was in the egregious United incident
or other after the egregious United
incident when the flight was overbooked
and they picked someone to kick off the
plane and he didn't want to go.
And so they called security,
they hauled him off extremely violently
and he sustained quite serious injuries
on the way out. Uh, which point
half the Internet went well,
he should have just left when he was old,
then he wouldn't get injured.
And the other half the internet
said, well, you should,
they shouldn't just beat people up
because they didn't want to leave a play.
And some people said it was
just one person's fault.
Some people said it was just something
else, but it was really a lot of things.
And there was even an editorial by,
uh,
an a British journalist who I probably
shouldn't name since this is going on the
internet, but who wrote an editorial
saying it's all of your faults,
yours because your sometimes late for
flights and that means that they overbook
flights in case people are late and it's
because of that overbooking that they
had to get someone off the plane.
So it's actually your fault for
being late for a flight. I thought,
well that's pushing it a bit far.
Maybe.
Maybe there is some kind of a point.
So what kind of a point is there? Well,
the editor result was the injury was
caused, right? Why was the injury?
Because well,
the guy refused to leave the plane
and also the security used force.
But the security won't even have been
there unless the airline had called
security in the first place.
Right now he refused to leave
because he needed to get to work.
But um, why did the airline even
choose him in the first place?
You could say he was a
doctor at the hospital.
He had a very valid reason to want to
get to work. Why did they pick him?
There are questions about whether
there was racial profiling.
Why did they pick those particular people?
Then there was,
why did they even need to kick
people off in the first place?
Who's fault was that? Well, nobody
volunteered. Why didn't nobody volunteer?
The airline offered them too little money.
Are they being stingy or why did
they really want to get home? Um,
why did they even decide to
remove people in the first place?
That was because the flight was to fold.
The flight was too far and they
needed to get some crew to Lewisville.
Why do they need to get some
crew to Lewisville so badly?
Was it some scheduling issue
and why was the flight to full?
Partly because it was overbooked and
partly because there was not enough.
No shows.
Now who's fault is that?
Is it the airline's fault for overbooking
or is it the people's fault for not
showing up?
It's both of those things.
And then finally there's the
people often miss flights,
which is a very tenuous
contribution to this situation.
But I think that changing any one of
those factors would have changed the
outcome.
But it doesn't mean that any one of those
factors by themselves is individually
to blame. It's really the
interconnectedness of the
whole system. So another,
another situation where people
often go, oh, it's really simple.
Whenever people say that,
it really usually isn't that simple.
It might be simple in a different way,
but it's rarely simple in the
way that people are saying.
And one is when they
talk about losing weight.
So I used to be quite fat and I lost 50
pounds and I would like to leave it in
that way. And so I think quite a lot
about this because it's quite an effort.
And then periodically someone will go,
oh well it's not rocket Thrones.
You just have to eat less and
exercise more. And I say, well,
even rocket science,
it's just applied maths.
So why do I put on weight? Well, I put
on weight because I take it more energy,
then I burn. And that's because I eat too
much. And because I exercise too little.
But it's also because of my metabolism.
And what affects my metabolism?
Well my mum,
the metabolism slows down.
If I eat too little and
I exercise too much.
So already we have the fact that I gained
weight because I eat too much and too
little. Am I exercising too
much and too little? So yes,
it's very simple situation together with
the fact that why is my metabolism like
that's also some genetics.
The amount of sleep I do and don't get.
And why do I eat too much?
I really like food. Um,
but also because emotions I emotionally
eat right. And why do I eat too much?
Well, why do I eat too much because
of emotions. Some people don't.
It's partly to do with my genetics and
partly to do with my upbringing where we
definitely had an emotional
connection to food when I was up. Um,
and there's also social
pressure to eat too much.
And some people say you can't
blame everyone else all the time,
but let's look at all the factors.
There is social pressure to eat too much
because people get bored with you if
you don't join in stuffing
your face when they are.
The social norms also causes emotions
that cause me to eat too much.
Then there's also time pressure.
If I'm very busy,
I get stressed and I also sleep less
and there's also life that holds his
emotions and then there's
also the entire food industry,
so there's a multibillion
food in this mouth,
multibillion pound food industry that
is trying to get us to eat too much
because that's how they make money and
they're also trying to get us to want to
lose weight and to try and lose weight
and fail so that they can carry on with
the Diet Industry that doesn't really
achieve anything and so advertising and so
on.
It causes us to eat too much and then
they make money out of us and so it's kind
of money. Maybe it's money
that's at the root of everything.
Then there's the fact
that if I do gain weight,
then I try and eat less and slow too
much and I get stressed about it.
And so I get all of these vicious
cycles and interconnectedness and a
conglomeration of factors. So now try and
tell me that it really is that simple.
I don't think it really is that simple,
but it really is this simple.
And the point is if you get used to
understanding interconnected networks of
factors, then this actually
is simple. The whole thing.
You don't have to forget huge parts of
the diagram in order to make it simple.
Your brain can comprehend this as a
single unit and that's what I mean by
becoming more intelligent in
order to make things simpler.
I did draw a diagram for the 2016 us
election because it's a classic case of
people yelling at each other about
who's fault it is. Here's my diagram.
I'm not going to leave
it up for very long.
But I did find it very helpful for me
to put all of these different factors in
and understand why people
are yelling at say,
so there are some people who just say
it's entire fault of the third party
voters.
But what they don't realize is that that
the people voting third party wouldn't
have made a difference if the
voting system were different.
So it's people voting third party and the
fact that they're voting system is the
way it is and so on.
So this to me is the logic
inside the situation.
Working out why each of these things
was there in the first place is more the
politics or the sociology of it.
But understanding the logic of the
interconnectedness right at the outset can
help us start to think about
all of the other issues.
It's definitely not
the full understanding,
but it makes it so much clearer to me.
And it means that I can see what's going
on with other people's arguments about
it.
I'd now like to talk about
relationships between things.
I mentioned relationships
between people just now,
but a lot of what I've been talking about
in the previous section was about how
things are interconnected
by different relationships.
And actually my field of research,
which is category theory is all about
studying relationships with between things
instead of their
intrinsic characteristics.
And so I've learned a lot from this and
my brain is very geared towards thinking
about relationships between things a lot.
And I realized that it can apply to many
important things in the world around us.
But starting from something quite banal,
like the factors of 30 so this
is obviously mathematical.
Maybe we can remember what the
factors of 13 oh they are one
and two three five,
six 10 15
I'm 30 very good.
It's not very interesting.
It's a bunch of numbers
in a straight line.
And we live in a three dimensional world.
So we write on two dimensional pieces
of paper and one dimensional straight
lines,
which means that we stuff all our thoughts
into a one dimensional straight line
all the time.
And sometimes they don't want to be
in a one dimensional straight line.
They have natural geometry.
And higher dimensions and I like to say
this is why I don't tidy the papers on
my desk because they have natural
geometry in higher dimensions.
They don't want to be stuffed
until one dimensional points.
So I'm going to exhibit the natural
geometry of this situation or find some by
looking at which numbers are
also factors of each other.
And I'm going to draw something a
bit like a family tree to show those
relationships.
So like in a family tree,
I don't need to show relationships across
two generations because we can deduce
those.
So we have 30 at the top,
like a kind of great grandparents and
then we have six 10 and 15 that go into 30
we have five goes into 10 and 15 two
goes into six and ten three goes into six
and 15 and one goes into two,
three and five so now we see
that it's the corners of a cube.
We can also see a hierarchy going on
here because you might notice that one is
at the bottom because it's the smallest.
And then two,
three and five are directly above it
because nothing else goes into them apart
from one which is that their
prime numbers. And then
the other level above that,
we have product of two prime numbers
and then at the top we have products or
three products are three 12 prime numbers.
So we have a hierarchy according to the
number of prime factors that each number
has. And if I draw out a picture
of the num of the prime factors,
instead I get this.
So at the bottom it's the empty set,
there are no prime factors. And then
one prime factor pairs of prime factors.
And then three,
and we can get back to the left hand
diagram by just multiplying together all
the numbers at each corner.
But now maybe we can see it didn't
really matter what those numbers were.
In fact, it didn't really matter what they
were at all. They could have been a, B,
and c. So we've turned on
numbers, intellectual, Ooh.
And now we have arrows that show
forgetting one thing from each set.
So this is also called subset interaction
but this is now it's very powerful
because we can,
we can try it with something else so we
could switch to doing the factors of 42
and we can draw a diagram similarly where
we start with one and then the prime
factors two,
three and seven.
Then the product of two prime factors and
the product, three time prime factors.
We can redraw the other diagrams and you
can see that the right hand one is just
a, B and c. It's the same.
The middle one looks very similar except
that seven has been put in place of
every five. So once we get as far
obstructors the right hand side,
it's become the same picture. It looks
less and less the same towards the left.
And this is the point of obstruction
that many things become the same.
And there is a particular feature about
the left hand diagram that I want to
point out which is that
six is less than seven.
Now that might not sound very profound,
but notice that six is higher than seven
in the diagram but six is less than
seven in the normal
hierarchy of size of numbers.
So there is a difference.
There is a tension between the hierarchy
in this diagram and the just sheer size
of numbers and that is something that's
going to be crucial in the next couple
of minutes as we move on because now I'm
going to show that this has become very
powerful at the abstract level because a,
B and c can be anything.
They don't have to be numbers, they
can be anything. So for example,
they can be three types of
privilege, rich, white and male.
And then at the next level down we'll
have people with two types of privilege,
rich and white,
rich and male and white male.
And then at the next level down just rich,
white or male.
And then at the bottom people with
none of those types of privilege.
And if I put back in the other words for
emphasis, we have rich, white, non men.
We have rich, non white
men. We have poor white men.
I should have said non rich
but it doesn't fit sideways.
So I said well we have rich,
non white non men,
poor white non men and poor nonwhite
men and at the bottom poor non white non
men.
So we have gone from a diagram of factors
of 30 to a diagram of interaction,
of different types of privilege and there
are many things I think we can learn
from this diagram.
The first is that each Arrow represents
a direct loss of one type of privilege
and it doesn't mean that all the people
who are white are better off than all
the people who are not white.
Because you can see along the second
level that there are some people with no
errors in between them. So there is no
direct loss of privilege along that level.
Now this is something that people make
a mistake about when they're getting
angry about the theory of privilege
because people sometimes point it a super
rich black sports store and say, look
at that really rich black person. See,
white privilege doesn't exist,
but that's not what white privilege means.
White privilege in the theory of white
privilege means that if that's super rich,
black sports star had all
the same features but was
also white, then they would,
we would expect them to be better off
in society and so it's not about the,
it's not trying to say that every white
person is better off than every norm
white person.
It's about losing one type of privilege
along one of these arrows and how that
affects people's experiences.
Now that's something else I think we can
learn from this if we just look along
the second row of people who are level
having two types of privilege each
because I don't think that they're
really level in terms of absolutely
privileged in society.
If we think about rich white women,
I think we can probably agree that they're
better off in society than say rich
black men who are in turn better off
than poor white men because it turns out
that money can mitigate for an
awful lot of other problems.
So actually it's more skewed like this.
And the same is true on the bottom level,
although actually I think it's skewed
further than that because if we look at
the interaction between the
the two levels in the middle,
I think we might be
able to agree that rich,
non white non men are probably better
off in society than poor white men.
Because again,
riches mitigate for many things.
And if we think about some extreme cases
like Michelle Obama or Oprah Winfrey,
I'm sure we'll all agree that there
are much better off than poor white
unemployed homeless men in the middle
of nowhere in America for example.
So actually it skewed more like this
and it's just like the fact that six is
less than seven.
So six was at a higher
level in terms of the cube,
but it was lower in absolute terms and
seven and poor white men have two types
of privilege. So they're quite
high up in terms of privilege.
But when it comes to absolute privileged,
they're lower down than people who are
considered less privileged than them.
And this has helped me understand why
some poor white men are so angry in
society.
At the moment because they are considered
to be privileged but they don't feel
any actual manifestations or
benefits of that privilege.
And I think that it's more productive
for us to understand this root of that
anger rather than simply to
be angry with them in return.
Seeing these abstract structures I think
helps us pivot or can help us pivot
between different situations that are
analogous in which we play different roles
so that we can understand what it's like
to be in different situations in those
abstracts structures and we can look at
analogous people in different structures.
So for example,
we've seen that in these three cubes,
30 42 and rich white men all occupied
and allow analogous position.
And if we look at just one type of
power relationship over another one,
we can see some more analogous things
such as that male people over female
people are analogous in a way to white
people's relationships to black people,
which is analogous to a rich
people's power over poor people.
Because each of these involves
a power difference in society.
We can then have a discussion about how
exactly that power difference manifest
itself. But there is an analogous power
difference in the sense of this diagram.
However, there is not an analogous power
difference between these two situations.
So the interaction of male people to
female people is not analogous to the
interaction of female people to mail
people because of that power difference.
And that is why that gives us a sense in
which men being sexist against women is
not exactly the same as women
being sexist against men.
And it gives us a sense in which white
people being racist against black people
is different from black people
being racist against white people.
And a sense in which straight people
being prejudice against gay people is not
the same as gay people in prejudice
against straight people because of power
differences.
And I think that's an important thing
that these abstracts doctors can help us
remember
together with the fact that something
could be not at the top in one context,
but at the top in a different context.
So in our original diagram of privilege,
rich white men are at the top. But if
we restrict our attention to non men,
then we get these people and we find that
rich white, non men are now at the top.
And if in fact we restrict our entire
context to say women and we think of three
types of privilege among women,
then we can think about rich,
white and cisgender as being all
three types of privilege, for example.
And now we'll see that rich white cis
women occupied the analogous position that
rich white men do in broader society.
And this has helped me to understand
why there's so much anger against white
women, especially in some parts of
the feminist movement at the moment,
because they can be prone to seeing
themselves as underprivileged relative to
white men because we women do all feel
everyday sexism every day and that is a
very big part of our lives.
But then as a result,
they can maybe forget how privileged
they are relative to nonwhite women who
have it even worse than them.
And understanding those underprivileged
and Oprah overprivileged aspects of the
same person can help us to remember what
it's like to be somewhere else in the
cube,
right?
We're all over privileged relative to
someone and underprivileged relative to
somebody else and so we could all pivot
between a situation in which we are one
thing and a situation in which were other
to understand it from someone else's
point of view and that way these abstract
structures can help us empathize with
other people and here are some
pivots that I do or that we could do.
So one is that as an Asian person I've
realized that I understand something of
what it's like to be nonwhite
because I'm not white,
but also I am probably among the most
privileged of non white people because
Asians occupy in many ways a much better
position than other non white people in
most of the world.
And so I can pivot between understanding
things from the underprivileged and the
overprivileged point of view from a
racial perspective. In terms of wealth,
I can also pivot because I don't tend
to think of myself as extremely rich.
I'm not so rich that I don't have to
work ever again. Not that kind of rich,
but I'm doing perfectly fine. And that
is a much better situation to be in.
Then people who are really struggling
who may be unemployed or working at
minimum wage. And so I think most
people, especially in this country,
we tend to view rich
people as other people.
And however we're all richer than somebody
and there somebody who is viewing us
as rich and turn. And so we can
pivot between those situations.
And here is the pivot that white women
could do because white women are less
privileged than white men,
but more privileged than non white women.
And anytime you take a two
adjectives where one of them is,
has privileged and one of them
doesn't and put them together,
you can have this situation where if
you only see yourself as underprivileged
and everyone else sees
you as overprivileged,
then antagonism will result from that.
So finally I'd like to talk about sum
up what I think intelligence is really.
And because I've been drawing all
these diagrams of interconnectedness,
I thought I draw one about intelligence
to show what I think are the
contributing factors to intelligence.
So I do think that intelligence
involves being reasonable,
being not just logical, but powerfully
logical and also being helpful.
So if you just sit in
a cave and use logic,
I don't think that's
particularly intelligent because
you're not really helping
anything. I mean, people can disagree,
you can disagree with me about this,
but I don't think that's very intelligent.
So what do these things mean?
I think that being reasonable
means you can be reasoned with.
And what that means is not
just that you use logic,
but you have some kind
of framework for it,
a framework for telling when
you should change your mind.
I think that's really important. You
can tell when someone isn't reasonable,
if there's no possible situation in
which they were, change their mind.
If there is no possible evidence that
would convince them that the moon landings
actually happened,
then that isn't terribly reasonable.
So what about being
powerful? A logical, well,
I gave an example of saying if you,
if you say something twice,
so if you believe that if you don't
believe in gay marriage because you think
marriage should be
between a man and a woman,
you've just said the same thing
twice. That's not powerful. Logical,
even though it's not illogical.
So I think being powerfully
logical involves not just
using logic but also using
techniques to build up logical arguments
and unravel logical arguments so that
you can actually get
somewhere with your logic.
And finally being helpful
crucially involves,
while some techniques were being helpful,
but it really involves using our emotions
because people are emotional beings
and if we don't use emotions to
communicate with other people,
then we'll just be throwing cold
logic at them all the time instead of
understanding what it is that they are
feeling and why they are feeling it.
So I really like Carlos
typologies theory of stupidity.
It's a slightly tongue in cheek,
but quite serious theory.
He starts by saying he thinks
that in any given group of people,
there's the same proportion
of stupid people,
whether those are scientists,
people who work at Google politician,
maybe more in politicians, um, professors,
Nobel prize winners, prisoners,
criminals, street sweepers. He thinks that
there's a exactly the same proportion,
stupid people everywhere and that it's
more your ever expecting even after
you've taken that into account. So,
okay, what does he mean by stupid? Well,
he has a definition and it involves a
graph with two axes and this axis is how
much you benefit yourself. And this access
is how much you benefit other people.
So if you benefit yourself
and hurt other people,
then you are abandoned.
If you benefit other
people but hurt yourself,
then you are what he calls.
Unfortunate.
I sometimes think of this
as being a martyr where you
sacrifice yourself all the
time for the good of others.
And I used to do this a lot and I think
that quite a lot of women do because we
think that it's noble and we're supposed
to to efface ourselves for the good of
other people.
I've eventually realized that that's
not terribly productive in the long run.
If you hurt others and hurt yourself
at the same time, you are stupid.
And that's what how he defined stupid.
Whereas if you benefit other people and
you benefit yourself at the same time,
that's intelligent.
And I think this is what intelligence is.
I don't think it has anything to do
with qualifications, degrees, education,
money status, job achievements,
prizes, accolades, any of those things.
I think it's about this and I think
that we should use logic and emotions
together so that we can benefit ourselves
and other people at the same time.
And in that way create a virtuous circle.
Because logic and abstract mathematical
thinking I think can actually help us to
understand how other people think from
their point of view rather than from our
point of view, which help us, helps
us to empathize with other people.
And if we can empathize with other people,
then that will help us act in a logical
way for them and for us all together so
that we can create this virtuous circle.
And I think it might be surprising idea
that abstract mathematics can do that
for us.
But I truly believe that it can.
And I hope that I can persuade many
people to join in with this lofty AME.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
thank you very much. We do have
time for questions, please.
Thanks for the talk. That
was really amazing. Um,
I also have a background in mathematics
and have always wished that I could help
other people and not be as afraid of it.
And I see that you're writing books to
accomplish this and I had always planned
to eventually create like a website where
I could offer free tutoring and then
end up with this kind of database
of questions that are well answered.
But now after seeing your chart, I
feel like that's the martyr route. Um,
so I'm just wondering if you have any
suggestions for what I could potentially
do or if this is something you've
thought about at length, maybe.
Um,
I,
I did start out by just making videos
of me explaining things to people.
And it wasn't to mater diminish at
the time because I did also feel that,
I mean there are many ways
that you can benefit yourself.
And one is that if you get a feeling of
self worth from having helped someone
understand something,
then you have benefited yourself.
And personally I do derive my self
worth from how much I help other people.
So maybe it gets a bit cyclical.
If I have helped other people,
then I have helped myself.
But what I didn't,
what I had to stop doing was
actively hurting myself. So I was,
I was quite unhappy in a job that I had,
but I thought that they should carry
on going cause I was helping people.
But even though I was completely miserable
and that was what was particularly on
productive about it.
So I think that the way in which you
benefit yourself can be measured in many
ways.
And if you feel like it's benefiting you,
then it's not necessarily martyrdom.
If it feels like it's hurting you and
that it's making your life miserable,
then I think it limits your ability
to help people in the long run.
So you help people tons for a week
and then you're burnt out and you hate
everybody and then you can't help anyone
anymore or you help people a bit less
and you also look after yourself or do
things for yourself and then you have a
much longer run of being
able to benefit other people.
So that's a some sort of
vague answer to that I think.
Hi. Hi. Huh. Amazing Talk.
And what a fantastic way to look at
the world. Um, one question though,
uh, when you're starting
to break down, you know,
challenges in life and
particularly looking at the,
the weight loss slide as
one one that jumped out,
I start to see a building series of
contributing factors to why this becomes a
challenge to overcome. Um,
how'd you get over that too?
Do you find that when you start breaking
things out into all the different
reasons why something is one way mentally,
it becomes harder to then
make that change? How, how'd
you get to that next step?
Uh, what I do is, well first of all,
I'm so used to dealing with
these huge diagrams that I have.
I'm less daunted by them, Megan.
The more you deal with them,
the less daunted you become and it
actually becomes clearer. It's very,
it's reassuring to me. Uh, and
that's not the same for everybody,
but because I've been trained in
this way of thinking for a long time,
it has become very reassuring to me.
And I think that what I can then do is
look at all the individual parts and see
which is the arrow. That would be the best
ones to try and break. And once you've,
once you've actually made clear
what all the connections are,
I mean this is a bit like a cognitive
behavioral therapy technique where you try
and see which area you can break,
but it is about seeing which one is
the weakest or which one would be the
easiest one to try and change.
And then you can try it.
And if it doesn't work that well,
at least you might have weakened it a bit.
And then you can try weakening another
one and then eventually there'll be
enough that has become weaker,
that the end result.
It doesn't happen quite so strongly.
Thank you for amazing talk. I
really enjoyed it. Okay. Um,
I was wondering about,
um,
so obviously we would all be better off
if we all use such logical mathematical
constructs, but I think it's clear
that especially on the Internet,
a lot of people do not.
Um, I was wondering,
are you optimistic or do you have any
tips for how we can engage people via
logic?
And if they're not even at all willing
to acknowledge that maybe that's the
helpful thing to do.
I
optimistic and that's why I'm here and
that's why I write books and that's why
I'm in education because I am
optimistic that we can change things. I,
I think that there are some very extreme
people who we might not be able to
reach immediately and that that's okay
and we shouldn't get too upset about
those people. But there are a whole load
of other people who aren't so far gone.
We shouldn't try. We shouldn't start with
the most absolutely difficult people,
but there are other people who are, first
of all, there are people who really,
really want to do better,
but don't know how.
And those are people we can
definitely help to do better.
Then there are the people who are,
who aren't really terrible people.
They just don't have the
techniques or don't realize,
and that once you explain it to them,
just like with things like,
uh,
sexually inappropriate comments,
some men,
especially all the ones
have got just that.
We've got used to the fact that they
can say those things and they don't
understand,
but they're not really terrible people.
And once you explain it to them,
then they get it and then they can change.
Whereas the ones who are
really absolutely morons,
maybe we can't change them yet,
but eventually if we swear
enough people in that direction.
So I see it as being a kind of continuum
and that these are the people that we
can most easily convinced. And then
once we've convinced these people,
then everything will have
shifted a bit further this way.
So that then we can convince these people
and then everything will shift this
way and we can convince these people
and eventually everything will shift and
then maybe we can get back to a situation
where it is not acceptable to be those
people anymore.
And one of the problems with the
current climate is that it has become
acceptable again to be those people.
And they probably were always there,
but maybe they felt like they weren't
supposed to show it or that there was not
supposed to be really like that.
And if we can persuade everyone to come
a bit further a bit the back that way I
don't think we have to just
flip everybody over overnight,
but if we can shift the
balance a bit further,
then I think that could just flip it
back again. And yes, I am optimistic.
The the people who are unreasonable on
the Internet are often the loudest and
the most annoying,
but I don't think that they're the
majority of people and I've seen enough
reasonable conversations on Twitter.
Even the,
I believe it is possible if we all slow
down a bit and try to understand what
other people are thinking rather than
immediately trying to show that they're
wrong.
You want an accomplished artist
as well and take off your book.
Say it's about art.
So where the art play
a role in making sense
of things. Oh, thank you.
I I think that anything is an art.
What's interesting because I
teach art students at the school,
the art institute of Chicago,
so we've had many discussions about
what art is and what science is and what
we've collectively decided one semester
is that science is about trying to
understand the world around us.
And the art is about trying to
interpret the world around us.
And that in order to understand the world,
you have to interpret it.
And in order to interact with the
world you have to understand it.
So they're really joined together. They're
not completely separate. And to me,
something,
something becomes an art if it's not an
algorithmic process that you just follow
step by step. And that's why
there is an art to using logic.
Because if you were just doing say,
computerated proofs of something,
then maybe the computer wouldn't be
using an art because it would be using an
algorithm. But, um,
when we're using logic,
we have to understand the people around
us and we have to engage emotions and we
have to pick ways of
speaking and we have to,
we have to use techniques to
understand what's going on.
And that to me is what makes it an art.
Hi. I also enjoyed your talk pretty
much. Thank you. Ah, ah, you claimed, uh,
uh,
in any group of people,
there is roughly the same ratio of
Carlos typologies claim neutral,
neutral about whether I agreed with that.
I agreed with his definition
of intelligence. Oh, okay.
Okay. Because it is somehow,
you know how to understand that one
would feel that in a group of more
intelligent people,
they were less martyrs.
Well,
only if you define intelligence like this.
If you define intelligence by who
has really prestigious degrees from
prestigious universities,
I don't know that that's,
I've worked in some of those places
and I don't know that that's,
I don't know.
Thank you.
I was struck right at the beginning
when you started talking about the
abstraction of too by the fact that that's
maybe straightforward in English and
there are several
languages where there are
okay
particles you put after the number
to talk about what kind of it is,
so they've got like more levels of
abstraction built into the language.
Does that change?
I didn't anything in practice or anything
in the application in the process
you're thinking about?
I guess the child development
aspects is way outside the scope,
but I think that it means like you say
that there are some more intermediate
levels, but I think at the level of
two that's still the concept of two.
Then there's some, some other
refinements of to blur and too blue.
And I know you mean,
cause they,
that there was this in Cantonese and it's
terribly confusing when you're trying
to speak it and it's not your first
language, but I think at the level of two,
there is still a concept of too that sits,
sits,
it's kind of above all of those.
And so yes,
at different levels of abstraction,
abstraction,
you get different subtle
nuances in between things. And,
uh,
I don't know what that means for we native
English speakers and whether we have
a less subtle distinction between
different types of objects.
But thank you very much again.
[inaudible].